i don't want any fat people to feel
uncomfortable at one of my gigs so next
time buy two seats i'm joking i'm dez
i'm joe shut up
i'm not having a go i'm just pointing
out you know
i was listening to uh the radio in
england a few weeks back radio four
quite high brow there was a discussion
about political correctness my name came
up straight away right and
there was this woman on there going oh
yeah well it's it's not right i'm uh
ricky gervais um he makes jokes about
fat people um he wouldn't make jokes
about gay people would he and being fat
is like being gay
what no it's not what
you can't choose your sexuality as we've
established you choose whether to eat
too much or not you know
with with with your sexuality
you're born
you grow up you discover you like
same-sex relationships and that's it
you're gay okay but being gay to be the
same as being fat you'd have to be born
be straight grow up knowing you're
straight but gradually and consciously
wean yourself onto [ __ ]
not all women i i mean the old-fashioned
ones you know the old-fashioned women oh
god you know the ones with wombs
those [ __ ] dinosaurs
[Music]
no i love the the new whip i know
they're new i mean they're great aren't
they you know the new ones we've been
seeing lately there were the ones with
beards and [ __ ] they're as good as
they're as good as gold i love them
now it's the old fashioned way and now
the old fashioned they go like oh they
want to use our toilets why shouldn't
they use your toilets for ladies
they are ladies look at their pronouns
what about this person isn't a lady well
his penis
her penis you [ __ ] bigots
what if he rapes me
what if she raped you
you [ __ ] turf poor
i don't know if you're affected by the
volcanic ash cloud um but i had friends
that were stuck all over the world and
they missed weddings and funerals and
they had to put themselves up in a hotel
for extra days i hadn't budgeted for and
they couldn't get their money back
because the airlines were saying no we
can't pay you because the insurance
companies won't pay us because they're
saying it's an act of god
what isn't an act of god
look if you believe in god
that's sort of a definition of him isn't
it
that he does everything isn't that right
everything is an act of him
he's all-powerful he's everywhere at
what he invented there was nothing
before him he invented time everything
he's across it all okay he doesn't miss
a trick and he's not absent-minded a
volcano going off isn't like him going
[ __ ] i left the oven on you know it's
i who are these insurance companies that
can decide what is and isn't an act of
god how do they know okay have they got
a hotline to god they called him up do
they ring ring ring
hello
uh could i speak to god please speaking
oh i didn't think you'd answer the phone
yourself
what do you want
oh um
that volcanic ash cloud uh was that you
yeah
yes that was an act of me all right
so i shouldn't pay out no don't [ __ ]
pay him a penny son no
brilliant brilliant while i've got you
here um did you make a tree fall on
steve baxter's car
there's a lot of steve baxter's um steve
baxter to acacia road houndslow it
happened at 2 15 on the third of june
this year 2 15 3rd no
that wasn't me
i was in africa that day giving aids to
babies
[Applause]
i know you can't say [ __ ] anymore
right
i can't believe you ever could because
that is the laziest labeling of a
demographic i've ever heard right so the
first one lands on our shores and we
gather around going what the [ __ ] where
you from right and he goes china and we
go oh you're a china man
i'm a what you're a china man
a china man yeah
what's my wife
duh lady [ __ ]
why don't you call me by my name i don't
know your name do i
it's ling
ling
yeah
is that your first name or your surname
both
ling ling
hair roll
right no right
right
father sitting at home just reading the
newspaper
this little girl comes running in she's
only six
hello darling hello daddy you've been
playing yeah in the park yeah
with your friends
well until the man came along until the
man came along
yeah a man came along and he asked my
friends to leave so it was just me and
him
darling come on come over
whatever happened
none of it was your fault okay darling
none of it was your fault but tell daddy
every detail what happened um
he took me behind a tree so now i could
see what we were doing oh god darling
and then what happened
um he took my dress off oh god what
happened next what
um
he took his thing out oh god darling and
then what happened
nothing that was it oh we'll make
something up
he was the ringleader
old adolph
that name has died out in it
[Applause]
he killed that dead didn't he
no one's calling their kid adolf
nowadays no little adults going to
school loads of brads and angelina's but
no that you don't hear the teacher doing
the register brad here angelina here
adolf here
i do that quick so no one can take a
picture of me doing that um
no but
people make excuses for him people say
oh he was stupid he was easily led he
didn't he didn't mean that what do you
mean he didn't mean that i said oh no
he's influenced by the political
philosopher friedrich nietzsche right
because nietzsche wrote this paper um
talking about a superman he said not all
men are born equal and hitler
misinterpreted this and went way too far
with it and uh
think of that you're a great scholar
you've done this work and you get a call
from the fuhrer and the viewer goes
all right nietzsche yes
yeah because what do you want because
just read your book
what do you think love it
love all that man and superman not
everyone's equal kill all the jews sorry
[Applause]
[Laughter]
not everyone's equal so kid all the jews
i didn't like that
i read between the lines
[Music]
[Applause]
i i i didn't mean that that's
terrible have you
you haven't been yep
you haven't been killing jewish people
have you
what
[Laughter]
[Applause]
have you been in jewish people
[Laughter]
a few
how many
six million
six million that's all i won't do
anymore leave it
leave it at six
that's terrible i won't do any more
stay for dinner well i will but be
careful in future
i will are you writing any other books
well i'm scared to tell you about it
i won't do anything what's a new book
called
my new book is called the gypsies do we
need them
we've come a long way from it being
punishable to total equality as it
should be of course in england the gauge
of consent same as heterosexuality now
um 16 and even gay marriage um although
ironically the one place that was really
ahead of the game fell behind a little
at the last election california they had
a referendum they put it to the vote and
they voted no
to gay marriage i mean in california
there's people going that's why we moved
here i mean it's a
it's a strange sort of bigotry that you
can affect someone else's lifestyle that
doesn't affect you back it's not like
they asked a bloke once said sorry um do
you mind if these two men get married he
went no fine okay jack them off then
what i didn't know that was good
that doesn't happen doesn't it that
doesn't happen
but
it's also a strange sort of bigotry
because these people that object to that
were presumably the same people that
said you know gay people were immoral
and promiscuous but now they don't want
to be monogamous and respectful in the
eyes of god and it must be so confusing
to a gay guy in california thinking
that's the bit they don't like with all
the other [ __ ] we get up to it's the
marriage bit that was so confused they
must go to judges and go sorry can i get
the rules straight what do you want to
know i just didn't know what we can and
can't do
ask away can i marry a man no
can i [ __ ] him up the ass and give him a
little reach round
please
can't marry him no but
can i pick up a stranger in the bushes
and take him home and jizz him and throw
him out in the morning all crusty and
homeless
of course you can yeah
but i couldn't marry him no
no and don't ask again
could i line up 15 men
i'm just riffing here
can i line up 15 men and just jack them
off
for a laugh if you want yeah
yeah
it would be difficult wouldn't it
jacking off 15 minute one it would be
like plate spinning
wouldn't it no
because you'd have you could only do two
at once really so you'd have these two
ready to blow but then they'd be losing
it and you'd go
[Applause]
[Applause]
never thought i'd say that oh